en el corazón de la región francesa
delphine y en este pequeño pueblo de 600
personas
silvia ha recuperado el gusto por la
vida a los 51 años acaba de vencer a la
enfermedad dos tumores extirpados de su
pecho derecho tuvo que vivir con el
miedo al curry de iu a veces también con
el temor de no sobrevivir al cáncer y
por foxismo pasquel siempre está en
nuestra mente porque sabemos que el
cáncer sigue matando a millones de
personas y por eso esta enfermedad da
tanto miedo porque puedes morir por ello
así que si pensé en la muerte una misión
buenas tardes señor este día sirve y
tiene una cita con su oncólogo y en
efecto le ha ganado la batalla al cáncer
pero las angustias permanecen tan bajo
no me gusta no me trae buenos recuerdos
al mismo tiempo hay que ponerlo en
perspectiva ya es pasado ahora hay que
avanzar es detrás de las puertas de este
mismo hospital abandonado por los
pacientes al principio de la pandemia
que conocimos a silvio determinada a
luchar contra él
a pesar del virus creo que no debemos
dejar las sesiones de quimioterapia es
muy importante y en mi opinión los
hospitales toman muchas precauciones el
riesgo es muy pequeño
la próxima revisión será dentro de un
año
sylvie sale del hospital llena de
esperanza y con un inquebrantable deseo
de vivir